everybody who has said
that hey look aaron rodgers is the guy
who is at faul or mike mccarthy is the
guy who's at fault and ted thompson and
everything
aaron rodgers bears some blame whatever
you think of aaron rodgers aaron rodgers
bears some blame because
the team was simply functioning
in a dysfunctional manner story after
story in tyler dunn's story even if you
threw out three or four of them there's
enough smoke there for you to think that
hey look aaron rodgers deserves some of
the blame for since october 1 2015
aaron rodgers record as a starting
quarterback for the packers 27 26 and 1.
that's not all ted thompson it's not all
mike mccarthy aaron rodgers has to take
some blame in this
and peter we talked last hour about
whether to what extent there was a
grudge held by aaron rodgers over the
fact that mike mccarthy was with the
49ers and the 49ers didn't draft aaron
rodgers in 2005 and did that poison the
relationship from the get-go and then
you pointed out there was still that
basic lack of respect for mccarthy's
abilities and one of the things that
tyler dunn focuses on is
aaron rodgers style that he's not a guy
who wants to engage in that direct
conflict that he's more passive
aggressive and this goes back to
the stuff that i was saying in november
of 2016 that prompted rogers to
eventually call me out and say don't
waste your time reading that crap and
there were two things he said one he
said on the sideline during games there
isn't enough energy well who's
responsible for putting energy on the
sidelines of a football team it would be
the football coach and two rogers said
that there isn't a healthy fear among
the players if you fail to do your job
you're going to lose your job well who's
the person in any football organization
primarily responsible for instilling
that fear in players it's the coach and
all i did was point out it looks like
aaron rodgers is engaged in a passive
aggressive battle with mike mccarthy and
you know what
it it was he did and that's how he
handled it and instead of having a a
man-to-man conversation with the head
coach and resolving their issues and
moving forward and realizing that both
of their legacies are tied to working
together and winning games and pursuing
championships that they're either in it
together or they're all going to fail he
opted not to solve the problem and there
are plenty of people responsible in
green bay all the way up to mark murphy
for letting it fester as long as it did
but think of how many championships this
organization would have
if they had everyone on the same page
working in the right direction to be the
best team they could be and the one
overarching takeaway from all of this is
there was so much dysfunction in green
bay over most of the last decade they
just couldn't they couldn't even get
back to the super bowl and they're lucky
they made it at the playoffs eight
straight years
you know there's one thing that that
bothers me when we talk about
think of how many super bowls they would
have won and things like that
the thing that bothers me about that is
that for the most part
if the packers had gotten to multiple
super bowls i mean if they had if they
had gotten to a few of them
more than likely they would have had to
beat new england to win the super bowl
there is this assumption
that aaron rodgers pick a number out of
the sky should have won four super bowls
by now or three or some number more than
one
and and i get it i
i get it i don't want to sound like joe
biden here i get it i get it but i get
what you're saying
the problem with that is that there are
31 other teams the packers don't exist
in a vacuum it's easy to say oh my god
they should have won four super bowls
but but let's be realistic about that
you've got to beat the best coach of
this era and the best quarterback of
this era and maybe of all time
what is that easy
and and so that's one of the things that
sort of gets my goat about all these
discussions but you know right now
in the aftermath of this the packers
have to take a very hard look at where
they are as an organization and aaron
rodgers has to take a hard look at him
if he doesn't do it you know he's
missing the boat on this in my opinion
yeah and peter look i i get what you're
saying that there's no guarantee you're
going to win the super bowl if you get
there but 2011 they were 15-1 the table
was set for home field advantage at
lambeau field and they got thumped by
the giants who beat the patriots that
year in the super bowl and in 2014
they're in seattle in command of the
game and they can't string together the
situational football necessary to win
the game starting with was it morgan
burnett who who inexplicably took a knee
after intercepting a pass when he could
have scored another touchdown and made
the margin even bigger than it was so
it's a little thing
i'm a firm believer that
football is so inherently complex when
it comes down to 11 guys trying to do
what they're supposed to do with 11
other guys doing the exact opposite
you've got to be buttoned up at every
level and you've got to have everybody
clicking and working together so in
those moments where games are won or
lost the thing that's going to happen
that's going to cause you to win is more
likely to occur and contrast that with
the new england patriots even though
they have issues from time to time
everybody does their job everybody does
what they're supposed to do and they
consistently get the most out of the
talent they have and even if it's one
more super bowl two more three more
whatever
there is a clear sense that this packers
team did not get everything it could
have gotten out of the presence of one
of the great quarterbacks of all time
whether that's mike mccarthy's blame ted
thompson's blame aaron rodgers blame
mark murphy's blame or a little bit on
all of them that's the reality of this
packers organization that we've seen
over the last 10 years
i agree with you mike i guess i would
agree with you conditionally but i would
stop
uh
at the line that says
you know
they should have won multiple super
bowls i mean if you get to
multiple super bowls obviously you have
a better chance uh to win them but both
years that you speak of
they would have had to beat the patriots
just because the giants beat the
patriots it doesn't mean the packers
would have beaten them and i'd like to
see a bill belichick coach defense
go against a mike mccarthy coached
offense uh we've seen that that movie
before and it's gone pretty well for new
england not every time but it's gone
pretty well for new england but
the the one last point to make about
this you know as you look ahead with the
packers so what can they learn from this
and how can they be better going forward
and i think the number one thing after
reading this story is this whole thing
about the the quote freezing out of
receivers end quote
that stuff if it's true
has to be absolutely totally
unequivocally nipped in the bud
and if
the head coach
and the franchise star quarterback have
to go at this head to head and whether
it's public private whatever that's got
to end
now
that cannot happen you know to bypass a
receiver because he ran the right route
and again i i'm going by this story i
don't know this is not my story so i
can't say absolutely categorically i'd
swear that it's true i don't know
but there's some evidence in this story
that at least the receivers believed
that that was true going forward right
now immediately that has to get nipped
in the bud
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports